[Music]
foreign
here are 40 dragon rolls from the How to
Train Your Dragon movies and their
animated shows tell us what your
favorite dragon roar is so let's get
into it
yes
foreign
so those are the first 10 rows and no
doubt a loud and awesome because they
are from the most noticeable dragons in
the franchise so the next 10 might just
have your favorite dragon in it
together
foreign
friends
If the previous 20 dragon rolls didn't
hit the spot then the next 10 will do
the trick subscribe and ring that Bell
icon to support us
foreign
[Music]
so those are 30 dragon rolls and now we
will showcase the last 10 to make the
total number of dragons to 40.
[Music]
foreign
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam